[Music]
they're loud yeah I know I just told you
that toll did you can you turn it down
for me please
please please please we're good Diane
yeah thanks Jean we cry about that all
right and then your diaper would be
exceptionally little exaggeration why
it's the truth
you got to turn your Bell tones down man
ridiculous that's rich um we did it
episode 400 is crazy I can't believe
we've found a way to talk about farting
poop pooping you sound like one of the
critics it's not only thing you do here
it's amazing though isn't it I mean yeah
there's a lot of stuff that goes on for
and for a happy 400th anniversary happy
for a demur furry happy for 100 I can't
believe it when we started this silly
show in our house and silver lakes
remember we sat at the kitchen table
I'll never forget this and we have a
discussion over what to name our new
podcast yeah and we I forget the other
candidates but it was basically what's
the dumbest thing we could call a
podcast and we're like to mom's house
were you going to Mom's house or mom's
house yeah oh my god I got wet there
yeah isn't that silly
it's so silly it's so silly I remember
writing down an old joke book some dumb
line about opening a restaurant called
your mom's house so that you could say
that to somebody just for the purpose of
it hey yeah yeah come on Cass
it's your mom's house here we are down
400 episodes right now
I can't believe living in the house at
Brown built dude I'm talking about the
guy that used to
work in this space made beautiful music
man we make we make different types of
music yeah yeah yeah
different stuff same strokes different
so everyone everyone's the same so
excited yeah what's your favorite thing
we've ever done on the show I think it's
for after the break here that's oh oh
yeah you know what though I'm still
caught up on that Brown story because
you started to tell me a brown story and
then I was like wait save it save it you
know I'm still thinking about court what
happened
yeah thinking about it you ready dude
yeah cuz I have a good story for you too
oh you do mmm okay yeah can't wait there
you go let's get it started
episode I got meet my mom watch that was
a 400 of your mom's house commuted
why is he gay for a female where for a
man to be okay with his female linking
his a is during sex she fuck what you
her bitch I'm a local who is Randy don't
bring anyone loving to this no man
welcome welcome to your mom's house with
Tom Segura Christina please
[Music]
Wow
400 episodes of that opening song it
never gets old to me I still like it as
long as you get tired I don't know wait
sound in your mom's house intro yeah I
love it I see the logo I love the intro
the sweet guitar lick like oh yeah it's
absurd every go oh oh my god I almost
just spilled my own cup come on toilet
paper I know I can use this now probably
go ahead and do the paper you just yeah
yeah yeah I can see where this is going
to go okay vamp for a minute okay so
yeah I love I can I think I've told on
another podcast before but Ryan match
the match man down in breast balls Beach
Florida he created that opening song and
a bunch of like the segment intros and I
remember sending him clips and being
like here's mr. t right here's coach ice
and but you know left it to him to be
creative with it yeah and he came up
with that well cuz we at the time we're
playing that mr. t clip that was a silly
one lagging anything wrong everyone
anything that said mom don't be real
c'mon yeah treat your mother right
attention mother road only came buddies
money because they were like your mom is
so fat he's like whoa whoa don't get
anybody's mother into this stupid video
and I would say you're mowing the
fucking stands yeah and then there was a
who's Randy that had nothing that looks
like you know what that looks like
that's your coffee but the Randy was uh
is Randy is Randy that was Hall of Fame
tight end for the Baltimore change yeah
a name I can't I just drew a blank on
his name but he had dementia and let me
look let me look who it is so I can I
can tight end kind of a gay name for a
position and foosball isn't it yeah the
tight end yeah John Mackey oh yeah John
Mackey
he had dementia and then his wife and he
were being interviewed yeah
and then another guy was like what's it
like living with him doesn't she
and then she's really it's really sad
actually it's one of the saddest things
Frank because she goes you know we
repeat the conversations and when he
asked me like you know when are we
leaving I tell him the Randi was a made
up name of a mechanic he's working on
the car and then you know that puts him
off for a while and then he asks again
like a ready to go and then they cut to
the interviewer an interviewer goes John
is Randy working on the car right now
like to try to like get in on the thing
right and then John goes who's Randy
right we've been at our hilarious scene
just like Stevie's hilarious right well
you think that's hilarious
I think he's really funny and they're
really making fun of me really dark
you're making fun of me it is dark but
Stevie doesn't have dementia he's
moderately touched retarded
yeah Stevie special but he's not
retarded you know Stevie's got a promise
he's got a lot of problems yeah yeah we
really really like that and then I
really like the Todd Phillips he drinks
yeah marijuana
ma-1 she's the smartest one in the whole
documentary
she's a Yoda she's like you shouldn't be
with someone that abuses you and you're
like how does this mention she's the
only one that says anything related or
and that's in the bed and is even more
disabled than her right has even greater
insight remember no I remember what she
said by did you remember yeah her friend
was like movie scene all right right
humans of reason shit right he's only
one flat out like looks yeah yeah yeah
that guy's a real shitbird you need to
get out he smoker gets mad they get over
real life stuff later on down the road
near the world gets mad he forgets he
always PluralEyes is the wrong word they
were changes people changes scene you
always gets the plural room I like when
he's all people call me snake because
I'm afraid of them nobody calls him when
you walk up to a rattlesnake do you
stand there or do you run like hell
take a chance again better not all right
it's like do I take a chance letting
people in or take a chance getting
stabbed in the back again
huh well I guess that's not the can we
sneak but you get the point a lot of
problems oh here we go here we go yeah
yes that's why I get my name snake frog
I ain't afraid of them
never has been except when I was a kid
right that would be a big part of when
you said that wouldn't get your first
statement right well you've never been
afraid of them except for the first 12
years of my chancel philosophy - yeah
because you never implies never I do -
never see our husband symbolic logic
yeah
you don't even need to take it you wrote
that bugga bug right talk to a Venn
diagrams that those types of things are
a big part of the culture these days
statements that don't make sense untruth
yeah ridiculous the news I think we're
all kind of becoming experts on kind of
things that make sense in those nonsense
it is tonight and I know everyone's
buying 1984 the George Orwell book but
it is double plus good it's called new
speak in that book and it's there's
totally in an entirely new lexicon and
it's new speak in its gibberish in its
double plus good I'd rather focus on
whether eating ass is gay or not agreed
and get to the important stuff this lady
makes a great point there's something I
really wanted to highlight this everyone
was like what's special about episode
four honey what's going to go on well
this clip was sent in and it made me
think of what would be a better
celebration of this podcast then if in
Episode four hundred we can get you to
open up your eyes open up your heart
open up your mind and ultimately open up
your mouth to lick my rear and ever it's
never gonna happen you just what can you
just for this episode no no for the
episode can you entertain the idea just
for this podcast entertain the idea I
mean it I guess I owe it to the
listeners there we go for 400 and I see
just for you doing that I think that
there's like a
I need to celebrate that you just you
know scared just that you're
entertaining the idea
[Music]
those are celebration horns and
explosions come up with me but the
morning crew let's I did even see this
but listen first of all can I ask you a
real question is this woman going to
threaten our marriage
wifey number two right here could be am
I looking down the barrel of the next
missus Agora uh this is just you know
what somebody that I want you to mirror
it's not the next missus cigarette but I
want you to be like oh I could I could
be just like this just listen no idea I
know you're big on logic you're big on
philosophy right know what she has to
say okay that's all of us can I say what
I'm afraid of with your asshole
pacifically what it's the heat
yeah hot down there the heat and the
sweat and the hair that's more than one
thing and the smells geez
well I hear you're Dobbs they don't
sound good I can only deduce that the
smells aren't good I'd I've heard you
shit I can't I can't unknown what it's
not as mad okay
so nice yes it is it's a nice man but do
you think you could get it sterile
enough that I won't contract some kind
of anal tamales absolutely sterile let's
let's jump on this journey together I'm
holding your hand let's go through this
whole thing and see if this lady can
convince you otherwise in bed no but why
is he gay for a female footwear for a
man to be okay with his female linking
his a s during six right she fuck with
your Herbie I'm here local let's go sir
right away right you know she's saying
that that's what she does now let's see
why she doesn't happen you're my miracle
let me lick his areas however I will
lick the shit out of his ass like niggas
eat please okay so right away you know
that there's ladies out there that go
really hardcore ingrain but they're not
like she's not saying like so she goes
right to those women are mentally
unstable soon
she seems really sweet I actually really
enjoy her demeanor and I like her yeah
I'm just not convinced she's right in
the head I don't know her well enough
but I don't think that's normal
not not here's an interesting statement
not that I had this fear anyways but
just I'm saying she's I don't think is
gay course not
I don't think it's any sexual it between
a man in a female right arm to go on
because it's between the man and the
female I agree that's like so and that
was never an issue obviously for us he
said this is gay but that speaks to a
certain segment of the population that
does have that apprehension so I you
think that's a very well I'm offended
personally because the use of pronouns
like she didn't she was an inclusive of
all the different binary right genders
so somebody out there yeah I mean but
what is the female what is the male was
talking about right mm-hmm so it's a
it's disrespectful literally but doing
it is it's just like the gauge
that's just like right but yes to your
point I don't think and she's right and
I've never heard it actually expressed
that way they said it perfectly she's
speaking actually to something different
Frank speaking homo tell me then right
who don't want to try it
she's not speaking to me obviously I'm
not yet like I'm on my hands and knees
I'm praying the rosary I'm making
dedications to it Rose are you speaking
I bet oh please you sound like your
mother I please please he told me what's
in it for me
Nick Maya what's in it for me let's go
there remember the dog food ring yeah
what's in it what do you need what do
you want some material thing I mean
absolutely I thought just knowing that
you're blowing your husband's mind and
giving them great pleasure not only
works when you're dating that's not same
as married kid doesn't work that way
really just not come on
okay how let me just think about it I
mean I want to go to Tahiti that's a
bucket-list thing yeah but we're not
going to do that right now right well
when Ellis is a little older and we're
in the bungalow overlooking the water
the one that I want to stay in yeah
that's when the a slick will take place
so I got to put off an athlete for
possibly a decade yeah come on it's
hotter there in Tahiti that's the
problem is that I'm actually making more
problems for myself just come on let me
just think here what I would like
let's be real let's be real leather
price tag on this on this sexual act you
think about what I really want in life
I'm at I want go on a trip I like trips
and I'm not terribly alright what about
a key realistic I mean and also by the
way if you agree to terms on this you
can't just go and be like I did I did it
I did it wraps so scared you got a
barrier you know could would you wax it
yeah you promise yeah hairless Carolyn
I'm afraid honestly I'm afraid of the
hair and the smell that hair traps will
keep it honest and and the heat there's
a lot of heat because I put my finger in
there playfully not in there but or in
the area yeah like to pretend spread
your cheeks and it's hot it's so sweaty
it's like a jungle okay I'll get it
waxed while you're gone this weekend
you're going to come back to a hairless
ass one from my birthday there's a
birthday tree June 18 it's my special
birthday yeah I get to lick your ass
kind of that happens all for a Father's
Day that's how that happened that's
what's going on all right think we think
it's waxed okay so that's out of the
question
signed off on that what do you really
want Tahiti I mean come on
Fiji a week in Tulum when I go starless
on the beach and stare at ships gotta be
so regret we're going to bring the boy
right now
Oh God it's no vacation at all is it I
knew how about a day where you watch the
kid and I go stare at the beach yeah
fine I went to Malibu or something yeah
check in this nice place alone so I can
but I mean we're talking like squat over
your face squat wait a minute and you
just any do just oh yeah tongue swirl
I didn't agree to that for this part of
the deal
no but I don't trust that your thighs
can I think you're going to smother me
if you do it that way well my asshole is
going to but not not I'm not here I
don't trust that you will respect me
enough to not come on you're your Joker
you're mean Rosaline you'll smother me
no
just I'll just now now stand over you
all just ease into it
yes lame-ass yeah now singing do you
like what about aye we do the we do the
die die change that's the only way I
would do the spread okay yeah the Manuel
Uribe remember I lay on my back yeah
I pull my legs have you changed my diet
I and you get home yeah I go to town let
me listen to what she I'm just not into
this dude I'm really not into it I'm
trying I'm really I'm really trying
around my brain and yes and you got to
be honest fellows it feel good to hear
us leave those of you that I had my
athlete bath you in shit feel real good
to me so I noticed you feel good be
y'all and y'all just uncomfortable
because if she feel good and you seen
your ass and you know that's a gay spot
you know I'm saying again I'm not
worried about the gay side oh yeah
anything between a man woman I don't
care even if it were I mean I'm just
honestly I'm honestly afraid of bacteria
and you know that I am
I'm afraid of vomiting no no I'm talking
about ingesting fecal matter I'm very
you know against it poopy in my mouth
full inspection if it you can't get that
on an eye balling there's just germs
bacteria
let's have fuckin doctors write in and
tell us how many fecal to oral cases
they've seen you get worms parasites so
that's the major concern yes honestly
it's sickness that terrifies me I mean
shit man that's how you get like
hepatitis when you go to other countries
it's fecal matter in food he's gonna let
me live with this burning request
burning to my babua to say Oh bubbly to
say ya know yeah I'm afraid we're just
going to have to not you just almost
signed up for I didn't find it I'm
afraid listen if we have doctors right
in if somebody can assure me in the
medical community listening that it
would not result in me getting hepatitis
or some horrific disease and yeah glad
course
if you tell me it's not possible though
it's dirty and people it is yours is no
I'm saying after a shower stop saying
like you're like dirty it's not it's not
finishing action I don't cares why
because I get leaky but all the time I
shit this is why I started brown the
shower because I make a brown and then I
wipe wipe wipe
and the brown keeps coming and that's
when I had to start it feel good to hear
you a is Lea speaking of somebody whose
finger doesn't close after childbirth
all right this is just dumb at this
point but um yeah it is it's a valid
point it's bacteria that you shouldn't
put in your mouth right I mean aren't
you afraid of that no no I think your
whole thing is nothing I think you
should lick face Buttle no I'm gonna
have him like mine can we talk about the
brown story I'm dying to hear the end of
it all right episode 400 the X doll of
adventure helmet off by men talent yeah
you actually really have talent I mean
yeah of course the funny train
production plops down dinner audio
calendar okay so let's start walking
through the beginning so oh well first
of all I just had an amazing weekend
amazed amazed amazed
I started in tuckson Arizona 105 I know
I guess just getting started as a
springtime and but first time Tucson
yeah
Poussin Arizona I brought Josh Potter
with me lovely
very funny super funny guy sweet guy cam
I like it yeah really great guy he he
killed it great shows so we started
there we did the Rialto Theatre so much
fun thank you everybody that came out I
had an absolute fucking blast there then
the next day we went to Reno you know
I'm feel like you're kind of glazing
over the important point to the story
what were you eating how frequently we
went to El Charro Mexican steakhouse
sounds like a recipe for OPA blaster
yeah yeah but no I mean it was delicious
you know I just had meat and veggies
that's
that's how I get down yeah and then I
need by the way I worked out before
every date for you he'll show good for
you
good that's what I do this part of my
routine hmm I mean the hotel shows in
three hours
cool I'm going to go to the gym spend
about an hour there then come back
shower get ready for the show can that
exhaust me does that makes me more tired
I add that make me angrier it makes me
awake oh right lurk I feel like oh no I
drank coffee around five I get jacked I
take a couple of dumps and I watch
networking oh yeah I can't I can't do it
that way I can't lay down and do a show
I don't like oh yeah I can lay down in
the green room and then get up on stage
I go from zero it makes me feel more
tired that's just the way I am like if
I'm if I'm laying around I feel more
tired if I'm active
I feel more alert I always feel like
when we're done making Fitness I have to
take a nap I'm tired
interesting now the only time that I
would feel that way is if it's like
balls of the wall you know blowout
workout but I don't do that I try to do
moderate so that like Oh heart rates up
I'm sweating but I don't try to go like
you know and that's Hanford high yeah
yeah yeah anyway so after that a Reno
which I think I'd been to Reno but I
remember we went to Reno to the Grand
Sierra Resort such a beautiful beautiful
theater the Grand Theater they remodeled
it unbelievable I mean just such a
gorgeous venue amazing history they had
I guess this is one of the old-school
Reno casinos that has been remodeled
Sinatra had your favorite yeah the
greatest singer of all time brought up
pop pop pop look at that game at the bar
hood up up those legs going on for days
so good he skated a bop bop not singing
anyway he didn't want it has the biggest
stage like actual physical square
footage of stage in the world yeah and
they said did you feel it that stage
well the stage that you're on has the
curtain dropped and is enormous if you
go behind the curtain
there's a plane there's bananas just
they land a plane honestly I don't know
it's a prop it's a prop for up for a
play that ran for five years but it's a
full-size plane it looks like a Ike
parked in someone's backyard because
that's how Big Bang Dave it's not even
it doesn't even stand out like whoa it's
just it goes on and on and on it any
normal boss feels it's like an airfield
hangar it's just huge painting
they have like they're like oh that was
part of a play that stopped running ten
years ago but we just left it here and
it's just enormous like fountain like
structure and they're like we just you
know don't know where to put it anyways
now you see like a shed it looks like a
like a storage unit and it's all locked
up and you don't even pay attention to
it like you want to see this and they
open it they're like this was Frank
Sinatra's room I'm like what do you mean
his room they go well he didn't want to
stay in the hotel and have to walk over
here so they built him a room cheese
backstage so that he could eat sleep
congregate and then walk out and beyond
like basically on today crazy I mean I
can get that imagine being Frank Sinatra
famous and walking through the hotel
every night well I thought it was
because people would as I said oh yeah
actually is what people to see I'm
they're like no no because he didn't
want to walk that far oh oh yeah I
thought it was the same thing as him
being so famous that people would stop
him but I guess not you know just a lazy
piece of shit yeah they didn't sprays it
that way but yeah I think I think just
wanted the the convenience of it like
yeah when's the show cool I'll be here
I tell you that that gives me so much
anxiety there's one club and I won't say
where because I don't want to let
everybody know where the comic sleeps
but there's one club where they put you
up in the hotel the club is in the hotel
and then your room is right behind the
stage there's a few of those terrible
really weird emotionally mentally you
need a break Vancouver's not bad the
comedy mix because that's in the
basement of the hotel but it's a nice
hotel you know oh so yeah but it's not
I'm talking about this club they
literally put you in the room that if
you open the back door
a stage there your room no no I don't
like that oh no I did that one yeah you
have I have oh yeah yeah yeah now I
remember - yeah I did that once and then
they asked me back and I go guess what
I'm not staying there though not saying
they're able to revise that deal well
and what's crazy is that like really
famous people have done that room have
stayed in that room and you're like wait
how is that possible that they give you
and then that room is also the green
room I like just go right yeah because
there is an agreement that's right
there's like a steps to the stage and
then you're weird guys like this is not
how show business works at all ya know
pretty funny but let's get to be
important I mean all I'm smelling is the
Dinan oh I'm chomping at the bit amazing
crowd in Reno I mean fucking crazy
yeah 2600 people but in Reno yeah I know
that many people lived in Reno it was
crazy and then last night the Chang er I
did a Spanish word for pussy that's
right we let me let me lick it my Ganga
we want it but what is panocha yeah
that's different thing sounds like a
Chang is actually in the tribal name
right of that trot in other words they
are something the Pachanga yeah
the hairy Pechanga yeah yeah so but
again another beautiful place they
really support a ton of money into that
place
I've seen the commercials I've never
been there really amazing and a really
really great crowd and oh my god
Maria came she was that last night so
that I may call her from the stage you
know only cooks very my show yeah first
thing when I see if she's like say I saw
yeah yeah I got talked about like a well
you do as you're doing right now she's
gotta go like oh ah which I she took
like really fast cuz Rose I don't go
like oh that's just a comp because I
feel like then I plan I didn't say you
go oh ah I just said you're like stop I
like try somebody Wed what she's like I
didn't say like ah
anyway she was there my cousin Jeannette
was there both of their spouses we had a
great night then we went out for dinner
afterwards
yeah and had a great time so anyways
this morning normally if if they hadn't
been there right after the show I would
have gotten my car I'm like I'm just
going to go back home right it's about a
two-hour drive maybe a little more but
since my sister's in town which is rare
I go well we should have dinner it's
like I'm gonna spend the night because I
think it's too late
so I get up this morning and I'm like I
get back we gotta do the podcast you
know there's things to do come in the
room and I'm like when is this shit can
I come hold on back up I'm finally
finally Gator the party story that I
care about okay you said you had Hotel
coffee now is this no no you're jumping
ahead you say I having a head before I
get there and you're saying let's go
back I haven't gotten there yet so I'm
sitting there and I'm thinking stupid
huh I'm thinking I got to get my car and
get back home huh when is it dump gonna
come I know it's I go is it going to
come during the drive and ruin this side
course it is yeah so then I go should I
tried it like it's not ready to come
should I try to force a dump out you
know I know what I'll do I'll make a
little hotel room coffee and see if I
can get the engine started you know so I
grew it I'm putting stuff in my bag I'm
packing I'm kind of like and then you
know you're thinking like how long just
driving to take right I have a sip and
I'm like you know I could sit here for
15 minutes drink this coffee and
probably do this but I don't want to
wait 15 minutes right now and it's not
ready now manage before we could
continue may I give you my travel tip
and this is for the listeners whenever
you're traveling go by the Starbucks
instant coffee go to Starbucks before
your trip or on Amazon using our banner
your mom's house podcast ahem
and you buy the instant packets I'm
telling you that shit is white it's
brown lightning you'll drink that and
you're going to shit oh shit
that doesn't make you shit nothing will
and that's great for travel but could
see I should have given you some so
that's how I feel badly I didn't know
so anyway so you're like do I stay sit
here finish this cup yeah did you finish
the whole no no no that's I'm saying so
I have a sip oh my god like I can feel
the beginning like the oil getting
grease but it's not ready or do I go cuz
I want to go when I get back alright
so I just go fucking I'm leaving I go
downstairs risky get the car and here's
a big decision I well if I have a
decision it's actually kind of made for
me I got to put gas in the car and I go
is there a Starbucks or a coffee bean or
someplace to get coffee for my drive
back I don't see one for the first half
hour of the drive sort which is really
annoying but then I realized that's
actually doing me a favor because if I
were drinking it I would have to dump
okay so I actually right now I'm like I
don't know 10 minutes from the house two
hours plus into this Drive and I realize
oh it's a good thing I didn't find
coffee so I do find some when I'm like a
right around the corner from the house
and as soon as I get in the house I say
hi to you
I have a couple sips of coffee and then
boom ready to go it was like a nice four
that's interesting you know what's
interesting is that when I travel and I
go to bar stocks and I get a double tall
soy latte yeah it doesn't make me shit
anymore it's not strong enough
well yeah cuz that that's mostly soy
milk double tall yeah yeah yeah yes yeah
it doesn't make me brown you got it you
got to go for the fire man you got to
get some of this
expresso expresso yeah interesting
interesting
yeah okay I share my story with you
please sure I mean you live along like
no nobody else has a brown story to
share as long as no one else is talking
just oh well okay so anyways last night
I made eggplant and I ate a whole almost
the whole eggplant to myself yeah and
then I went to sleep and I didn't have
any farts all night which for sure is
like
yeah eggplants make me fart so bad yeah
I know that for sure and I had any kind
of orange and I was like concerned a
little like what does that mean it does
it mean that like can you make your body
immune I don't think to the farts ya
know because I eat brussel sprouts now
and I don't really get as many parts as
I used to the beginning so anyways
no I'm serious I think you can build a
resistance to the food that gives you
the fart and you get less parts over
time yeah so I'm having like no farts
and then this morning I drank my coffee
and I took the biggest shit
of my life I mean it was so much and I
thought is that weird though I didn't
have any like very good very good
yay but I didn't have any warning shots
like there was not nothing so what's
your theory on this sounds really
interesting so far it's your my theory
is that I've grown it you can build an
immunity to so you're not having you're
not having that everyday eggplant so not
every day but I've had it enough to
build an immunity you know it's like
when you take a little bit of the poison
every day you've got to build an
immunity to it interesting I don't know
if I believe that but I do know I
believe that in theory I still believe
that that theory applies here cuz it's
not like you're like constantly eating
this stuff for you to build the immunity
I had enough you think so
I do Brussels sprouts - ant dried
apricots those may used to make me far
really bad they really don't do that
anymore
hmm ok I'm in the shed
yeah there's a reason I think I found
out her reason yeah that's why she's in
the shed she needs this thing I have a
bunch of girls here if you see my
regular sites you fetus suddenly all
kinds of pictures of me and other girls
Nvidia is going to be showing a very
short other girls and I
and particular videos and problems I
heard a rooster crows well what would
have it taken for you to go down this
path you see not a lot like how could
you have been do like others videos on
my site it's like they're going to be up
soon being some other girls I have gas
any turn on you Barton or camera uh 2009
could happen he said like had nothing
picked up for us yeah I mean we were on
us I wouldn't be with you if this is
doing I'm saying you're alone for sure
you wouldn't support me in my business
venture definitely not no no no well I
mean she doesn't hate where we were at
our broke ass we have no money
yeah nearly married I mean this is easy
money dude as far as I'm concerned okay
no I think no dude easy I'm not married
to this I mock this on our podcast I'm
not married you know how fuckin I could
do this in a let's say 2007 instead of
getting engaged we break up a year later
are you in a shed farting in my camera
yes well possibly because look when I
married you I mean I just transitioned
into being a full-time feature I got no
money and I leaned in on you and you
know we because of you at a show would
have been like hey pretty girl
you're thinking about other ways make
money and you're like oh my god know
what everyone come by my shed this week
and don't raise it you plenty of
eggplant pretty good where your pajama
bottoms - that's a weird choice the
pajama bottoms veggies yeah one so
yesterday I got half a me for lunch
vegetables the Roosters yeah publisher
that is the best idea that she's a
Christian movie you see your craft
ah that's mainly $100 - that fart I know
Kyle she's in the veggies just like you
blonde healthy big cans yeah just like
you healthy diet guys I could do I could
so do it it's really not a big deal
okay I'm gonna try to go back to the
party and put out without induced
pictures yeah I might be back though
because I don't think this is real huh
oh is this he got up on her tippy toes
for that one she got up she was like oh
I wouldn't do it that way
I would make mine more playful the way
King a stripper does I create more
scenarios more whoopsies oh yeah
different locations the shed is not
exciting to the viewer I don't like to
shed that she's out there making it like
this yeah I don't like the shed aspect
of it listen I don't care
I like that early I would I would be a
little more fun about I know that she's
like my phantom you believe it oh my
gosh you're so barren oh my god now in a
response we came up with a very serious
topic discussion we normally don't get
the serious on the show but we were
wondering what do you call it when you
have to dump but only a fart comes out
yeah that was a big big conversation
that started last week a number of them
came in here oh wait can I get on that
I'm glean from Twitter sure sure okay at
real big Kong writes a no shit but a
fart should be called a Chanel shit and
nope combo alright so again just to make
people clear on this Shore we've said
that when you think you're going to fart
in you and you should it's a shart what
about when you think you're going to
shit and you only fart why isn't there a
word for it right yeah okay this one is
from at Darryl be dumped fake ghost shit
counter shit charlatan oh my god I like
that one a lot or impostor looks funny
all strong suggestions
I like counter shit or charlatan I'm
kind of leaning towards a head and
booster
boosters are fine okay just watch the
latest episode mommy's is from at secret
moves MMA what if the opposite of shark
was farsh which also sounds like farce
yeah I mean that's a suggestion a foop I
heard that one that's not bad
I almost said there's a seduce a pseudo
deuce I said yes at chase leopard rights
when you think you're going to shit and
you only fart it's a Shar n't that's
pretty good yeah somebody said there's
no work word combos for this it's just
simply a solid fart I just a
disappointment
a brown downer oh I like a break came in
Rachel from Portland good one Rach
yes somebody calls it a Macbeth I like
that yeah is a tale told by an idiot
full of sound and fury signifying
nothing
very good it was said that like that
moms when you go take a shit oh it turns
out to be a - it's called a shoot oh my
god ah tip said it's a poltergeist wow I
like that one a lot
ectoplasm spirit Fuu yeah I just said
you're not taking a shit home and you're
frowning Sartre failed what Brown frown
yeah that's Kate the resident BART
channel thank you for all your cares hey
where I'm leaning yeah I like pool tour
Guist a lot what you guys are highly of
you funny charlatan and I like imposter
it's really good it's really hot in here
tube just like an IV outside today and
yeah so I'm in a room that's been closed
all day see how I shed yeah start how
much money consumers really high fifty
dollars a video yeah to ruin your life
that's a thing is it really worth it
is it working I think she might be
pushing a little too hard I heard as I
think she's gotten a few out she's like
I gotta get a few more out in the body's
like
it's going to be a little extra on the
end of this one this is that sounded
like she gets her
Oh Nancy there she's all winded yeah my
work here is done
can you hear that
it's like growling out of my camera
tailbone oh thanks
god it's like Ryback we are we feel yep
huh I mean how much could she make
seriously no no no I'm uh
I mean $50 a video dude and this well no
because there's there's got to be
multiple you know viewers guys it's like
so do you think they're paying feeling
they're paying $50 each also it's a
subscriber base I don't know I'm trying
to guess like to figure out like if
she's putting this up somewhere right
and she's obviously speaking to an
audience group people that are used to
coming there maybe they pay I don't know
$10 $20 each well the demand to put out
content I mean she's really got to be
farting every day every other I'm
rethinking being married to you if
you're doing it I'm thinking maybe it's
a good idea I'm thinking of the what
ntral what's the pros just a sheer
volume yeah yeah as long as we can get a
you know a decent because you're just
the upfront costs are just the food to
make I fart it and I already know what
makes me fart so there's the thing as
though yeah well they're 40 years of
doing this I mean I've been in this game
long enough I know it works for me we
want to call the site fart mistress oh
that's probably taken I'm sure what it
looks yeah
fart mistress 40 because then then I
combine like the milf genre in the first
yeah no I mean what fart mistress did
you mean fart mistress yeah I meant it
mistress fart porn two mistresses but
there's but there's not fart mistress
calm as when I'm 40 fart mistress 40
yeah because then it combined my second
the milf and the fart genre to you know
you're right I think that's smart
marketing mistress the farting milf
that's another one from a writing
standpoint that no I typed it in as URL
no results for smart mistresses yeah
hello yeah let me buy it up now well now
someone's going to buy it
ooh bad virus what bark mistress is here
now how much content do I have to put
out is it once a week or daily like how
these porn sites work tell me I don't
know I don't know how that stuff works
no sure I don't know how the uploading
content - yes you asked my friend Yoshi
you know it's always alright but I mean
to keep my subscribers engaged and happy
I would think at least a couple of week
alright and then I got a tweet the
videos and but then you're just giving
away for free right a little teaser yeah
yeah see the whole thing
well that's the thing that the teaser is
the whole show pretty much I mean a fart
is every second it could be the teaser
could be like Oh guys ah big ones coming
see that well that's what I worry about
in that genre as it's so limited
creatively like how many said why don't
we get more native with it but I mean
it's a so I have to fart so bad
ah like we need to really think of a way
to reinvent the fart mister genre yeah
that's true
I mean what if it's an accidental thing
like we set up these scenarios where
like I'm at jury duty and then I'm like
oh my god don't have to fart so bad I'm
afraid to let it out and you're like
just let it out
yeah and like I start in public and
stuff yeah could that be a genre that
could be a zone right yeah of course
about the car fart
where you like a hot one and then you
leave you come back it's still there
that kind of stuff see you're getting
more creative by the moment I mean the
other cool thing is that as you're doing
that out there in the world you know
that a bunch of guys are enjoying it you
know I can't look anything Rees is all
guessing from Keith Osso gross
he's the worst he's not know what he's
so gross coming he's like right now
oh my god McCall guess I'm coming up
dude let's all guess I'm coming up now
have you been doing your exercise de
meses lessons every day I love it you
can't be busy
how's it going right yeah rajat rock rap
hundred fifty fifty fifty three times
now you get the penis out yeah you put
in a lot of people they never said yeah
census yeah never circuit again through
the skin and you get the oil in the hand
and your right ankle ready to rock rap
rap rap especially on the Klan penis rub
them 50 times rest okay
because you make them strong and not
sensitive oh he's so gross with the time
one one right side I can't move you can
for left right we've come from with the
time back to depart now I like okay how
often am I doing this you have to do
every day until you can control every
day every day just Jack your dick 300
times that's what you've been doing
that's why he's the expert how the big
expert in a trifle is a dick Jackie
suppose that you Colin just a pervert
well that's what all these clowns are
they're like I ride my dick maybe I can
teach to other people he is so nasty I
hate his hand Rob Rob Wow look at what a
trap mom will you try it one drop try it
it's three hundred strokes total I'll
try it you go down and then yet a pulled
for it he says some people were
circumstances I know well you know it's
just lame he's all to the wind right
means but I mean yeah yeah 50 50 50 now
it's just down down down it's not down
back you know I'm saying right right so
you're just what he's trying to get your
your ding-dong be less sensitive
straining everybody throw up from coming
so hard yeah he is so nasty
I don't know I seriously okay okay okay
okay okay would you rather good kiss
shacks took these oh and we saw it look
like we saw what shacks feet looked like
okay
oh no you know you got to bring it up
you can't do war not sure oh you gotta
bring it up man we did in the last
episode though but if we're talking
about if you're listening to this just
on the podcast please Google shacks feet
we're two foot you're gonna die I mean
it doesn't even look human the poor guys
been playing for his whole life his feet
are just mangled well here's a shot
that's been said nanny ah
alright so kiss that kiss that pussy or
yeah every time you're masturbating you
got to have the Chinese guy coaching you
and he's like rub rub rub and then you
play the audio of him Jack you leaning
as you ejaculate
so you every time I jack off now you
have him while coaching you and then
when you come heals with you he comes
with you to the hotel rooms like when
you're on the road right Rob Rob every
time you do your fifty busy busy he's
coaching you he's coaching you from the
cherries like Tom rap rap rap I think I
would deal with it I think it's fine I
think I don't mind it I don't mind it I
think I like that he's an expert and I'd
be like am i doing it right I'd like to
have like a little little expert opinion
in there I'm gonna be into it I like it
you're sick I like it I think he would
be like you forgot to left them oh yeah
I forgot he's like Tom like he's rah rah
rah
he's like a trainer that goes that's why
you put your knees down get back up
there right now so you definitely
wouldn't come fast because you know yeah
okay like I would have major control
kind of would you know what come to
think of it he should be like
concierge service Lee you should come
your house and teach you how to rub
rubber because I way you won't come I
think it would be mildly difficult to
stay hard if he's sitting there looking
at you like Robin you're like um dude
why I can't really get it up right now I
can't believe you feel that way yeah I
think I would have a little bit of
difficulty yeah I'm terrible
yeah the shot I would take checks foot
any day especially on the glans penis
now would you rather have sex with him
nope
either option or yet to put Shaq's whole
foot in your coochie he's yeah done I
mean it would hurt but I'd find a way
why I was created to person out of the
ATO why would you do that over that
because that guy's so fucking gross dude
the truck guys don't work Rose but he's
the that's the worst yeah he's not he's
nasty pervert
he really is nasty pervert you're so
minding that guy at all how about Steven
Seagal yeah for him
Steven see oh really
he thought that repugnant do you think I
was just like a you know sweaty fat
older guy he's not that bad I mean he's
got that silly hair but that's you know
that's nothing
he's probably way more annoying yeah
yeah I could listen to him talk about
himself all day but you know I am the
king of in promise for pretty long time
so you want to deal with that
yeah oh you all about sex you think that
guy is annoying about sex
yeah moment you choose Seagal he's going
to be like I've made more girls come I
know in the last oh I know is you guys
even imagine and then you'll start doing
like how I am
wait a minute let me hold on let me just
uh let me talk to you pussy for the same
nasty is both nasty but right I think
that Chinese guys grow more charming why
is he the grossest I'm not attracted to
him at all I don't think he's gross I
don't like his I actually can't believe
you find him grosser than such a hall
yeah yeah real you know why I think
because the old Chinese guy could be
like my granddad I feel like he's too
old he's not that well yes he's like
your sweet old Chinese granddad I don't
like him he's too nasty do you like my
jacket is dick and stuff I want to hear
that Dad buddy hey got to tell you
something but that I'm I'm poly and I'm
bi what Zac I'm poly and I'm bi
one of my favorite moments of the show
is that yeah you go okay buddy
all right batting for both angles all
right so email came in Mali and I'm by
audio issue with the podcast okay hey
Hitler I've noticed in the past few
episodes that every time you say that
you are playing a clip of someone puking
or farting I never actually hear someone
puking or farting but I'm even and even
more obnoxious sound that turns out to
be Christina's voice it's a complete
turnoff for me and I'm sure it is for
others also after glassing through the
internet for hours trying to
troubleshoot I came across a web page
dedicated this type of disturbing
problem it said this issues actually
stems from a complete lack of
personality ever is talking audio
interference in parentheses Christina
this makes perfect sense as Christina's
personality is as dry as an old lady's
vagine in the Mojave Desert I suggest
adding more of Tom's refreshing and
sweet personality as well as his water
champ skills to combat combat Kristina's
obnoxious and embarrassing personality
please fuck my Triple D slut wife
Kristen Kansas well crash from Kansas
you can suck much it's my ass yeah tell
them all about it well I mean it's a
silly silly you silly yeah the whole
thing is silly
I'm personally
jump on the water Jim everybody knows
who brought the water to you today
before the show and by the way you
haven't even cracked yours open that's
true so fuckin beer babe baby you know I
fuckin hate that no no I'm not gonna
listen I know that you've done it you
push button again I just fuckin saw you
not listening
alright we're done you think I was born
yesterday we're done I'm not putting my
headphones on why because I know you got
some nasty showing them no I don't I
don't I promise
lies I promise let me see your hands no
you just play something till I'm setting
up the next thing to play uh-huh I have
to play something else Jean yeah go
ahead
okay so we had oh this lady that was in
the UK lady who tried to make a chassis
at Europe show the clip and then all
look at ladies standing there
uses her hair dryer as a make-believe
cars and bikes going down you know all
of them down the road it had to stop how
many cigarettes did you smell we
describe her for our listener and um
this woman I can be related to this is
also very Eastern European look yeah not
good teeth
soggy mushy mushers and they're mashed
into a tube top which when you got big
hangers you cannot wear a juice off the
table freeze yeah I mean there's a lot
going on though you lose a lot of you
know I can't you do it well I mean it's
a bit of a weathered look Haggard full
life
I prefer yeah there's I mean if you were
to just crop out everything else you
could definitely make this a Zim yeah
well how old do you think she they are I
think they are much younger than they
look I think I worry that they are like
55 I may look 80 bucks
I don't look do they have been you know
why it's called yeah hoo-wee zippy
Bandar road yeah she's been writing it
hard drinking hard so what she does it's
a great bike and Costco buzz room I do
love shit like this though so she holds
out a hairdryer hilarious and it has the
effect of making these cars slow down I
love it I think when you get on our
stalls and bikes going down and you know
all of them down the road it had to see
the hallways out yeah and those all up
or down the road those choppers are
something listen we're not even now I'm
just listening to the voice oh right
simply by picking up one of those
I was going like sighs look I have
mangry so many people's brake lights go
on a Nauticus hey driver lover I love
vigilante shit like this what do you
think of it through I think we have l1
l2 l3 and I'm going to score them five
five five five five five five five five
five Jose yeah look like artifacts it
look like and then like we discovered
these in their over 60,000 years old
Paleolithic woman I think - um she
reminds me of those gypsies we used to
watch a lot yeah gypsies aged poorly as
well yeah she might be gypsies yeah yeah
yeah actually that would make more sense
definitely - guys look at here I am
calling her she over and over ah so rude
the thing is is that you know you're on
television yeah and you think you
wouldn't wear the tube top mashed your
tits down no makeup you like just clean
up all of that good traps there's no
solace
she's got traveling yours you hit me old
heck squat huh if they don't like it at
all I love her
I live here my friends live here my
friends children is here and if we talk
behave in our own street how the hell
are we going to take in the world all
right yeah the point I do like about
tartar method what about what's what's
happening behind her in the sail riding
this there's like a yard sale man maybe
not please she's like 41 years old
straight I'm sorry I this year
what if she was a young she could be
sometimes these folks don't age very
well
yeah they balaam live on a diet of like
Wonder Bread real hot cheetos and Oh
Mario let's see yeah let's see do you
prefer greater than should I go to good
homes and some Cheetos and takis that's
what you want to hear at 3:00 or 4:00
all right whatever you want cheap well
it's 10 after 2:00 so what do you think
well I need to take a swim after this
but as long and ooh that okay
right sure okay so keep talking I like
her initiative with doing this with a
hairdryer I feel like we need to do this
on our street because so many assholes
just whoosh whizzed by and we live in
the burbs man you should go in that shit
there's kids on bikes yeah you know what
man you feeling all that no I have
relatives that look this bad
definitely I got a couple right now that
look like that that's just hard I have I
have some rough-looking relatives yeah
but that's hard living no out of the
border right no dentistry or medical
care no access to it yeah she's not
doing Pilates twice a week sick and do
primal diet stuff like that yeah I like
your sounds oh yeah yeah yeah no no no
just cause his bikes going boy you yeah
my goodness yeah one of my favorite
things that I saw on Instagram I think
it was was at that Scottie Pippen um
page anyways I think that's who posted
this this dude posted this video of it's
kind of like that what's it called when
like deke like the the court shows you
know or like they confess like that they
let the TV judge decide oh yeah banished
and this one was just outrageous present
man but it's all in Spanish but just to
highlight that somebody said this on TV
okay so okay I want our esta parte del
cuerpo con la pampa yeah okay yo
sesamoid waterloo back so his lady with
a studio audience is telling the judge
he told us to uncover our backsides and
as we were still wearing those
transparent ropes okay I was the fourth
one down
right yeah okay yosaku MOA cuarto lugar
de Pras empieza Santiago mo Oona's
respiration ahi tada I started hearing
heavy breathing you know hey amigo via
Navarro
we're moaning behind me pronto yo siento
se como una lengua espera que me pasa si
por el trasero out of nowhere I feel
someone's tongue liking my body my god I
tried to hit him buddy grabbed me and
said I was ruining the ritual oh yo soy
yo Hernando sweet what porque si Senor
me balmy Ahana so this guy told me that
he was going to heal me right hello
Sammy lengua como se era una y no se ya
voy okay so she saying this I know
that's what this guy licked me on the
ass and I was supposed to seal the deal
like on the ritual something about to
commence
yeah go ahead touch it positive yeah
those guys it's not the same thing in
Spanish tossing salad no what would they
call that they're crazy I think she said
one here she says over here I think I'm
in fact that if I saw Nicola Hank that
Basin Inglot eye hindi I don't know like
keep the black kiss is that what she's
saying I don't know I think that's what
she said right that's what it does I'm
your guy Shalom lingua Yummie o Lieber
yevo Sam Acuna lingua same in Gaston San
Nicola no so this guy who looks like a
quirky spiritual guy right look you see
him being like a top of a mountain be
like yeah spend a month here don't talk
so he has this he's bald he's older he's
got this weird white shirt that has like
no collar right like and he's telling
that the court now that dogs and cats
kill themselves with their tongues Jesus
cured a blind man with his saliva
I never read that one okay I know I know
yeah why the anus why I know fortune
silent solar model because all the bad
stuff comes from a trail trail okay
don't just I guess
your scooper another so he spits on
their hands it why did you show that is
it upsetting yeah I feel like so many
things on your mom's house it never
fazed me that's like one of those things
yeah because it's a holy man and you
taking advantage of people's religions
oh well he's not taking advantage of
anyone he's feeling people I hate that I
hate that people trust him it's so sad
thanks for bumming me out
well I thought maybe you wanted to feel
a little that's what I feel right but I
like these people were like this is
charge and they're like okay pull your
pants I'm okay now Brad your taste
gotcha
like wouldn't you be like fuck you I'm
not pulling my pants down crazy train
lick your ass for a minute make you feel
better right but what you wouldn't
protest at that level let me ask you
this
I kind of feel like this is actually
great evidence for your honest case in
getting you to kiss might give me the
black Jahna
it's a holy man's ploy yeah cleans all
the impurity on earth as you can see
this very spiritual man has cured many
people by spitting in the unhealthiest
of places and I feel that counsel would
preserve me by cleaning my is everything
uh dirty evil oh I think we should take
you to a yoga class that you can learn
to lick your own butthole okay that is
not what I signed up for that's not what
I want
can I just take a rag on a stick and wet
it and then mash it against your
butthole and be like that's my tongue
mmm it's the same thing it's same thing
it's the same thing
what's what's Mario saying Maria just
said I challenge you and Bert to a water
challenge okay I will win and if you
want a bigger challenge we can do a
pull-up push-up post Tito's challenge
and I'll still win
of you hmm first of all the water
challenge wouldn't be with him and be
with you and me that's the she's not
getting it she doesn't understand that
no would you want to take her up on that
challenge no because I've never been a
showboater like you are will you ghazal
a gallon and then own the word Jim it's
not about that it's about hydrating
constantly throughout the day so that I
don't need to binge I understand you're
been Jahangir I'm not I'm not insisting
you're jumping ahead would you want to
have a day long water challenge I don't
need to challenge I know exactly who I
am and I a matter chance you don't want
to compete in this why would I
okay just to be the way what's the point
to say who drinks the most or who drinks
who drinks the most in a day not a binge
moment in a day okay but that's the
things like that you're going to binge
you're going to push yourself getting
harder than you normally do I could
drink it all day do you want to prove
that you're the water champ by partaking
in the competition with Maria are with
you with the two of us it's a three-way
competition what is but what a shift she
doesn't have anything to do with it
she's not a part of this thing she's
saying that she's the water champion and
that wants to death row nuss I don't
want to do this now a lot why would I
want I don't like doing contests like
you a bird I don't like putting myself
through suffering for the point of what
no I don't like it I know why I know in
my heart Who I am I don't need to
fucking complete you know in my heart
Who I am
I already know that I am the champion
why would I even need to compete demean
myself debase myself to compete with
fucking peasants you and Maria are jokes
you guys are fucking you're not even in
my league why would I compete with
dilettante drinkers okay you guys are
fucking Sunday drinkers but this thing
I'll know this when you say things like
that you can back it up with what you do
it's that's the whole point
yeah I know I'm hydrated the doctor says
I'm perfect everything's perfect I've
been to a urologist the guy told me to
stop drinking so much so you won't take
place
take care in the competition no I don't
believe I don't like doing stuff like
that
that's a fucking waste of my time okay I
would like to accept Maria's challenge
for the water drinking competition oh my
god
what what are you gonna do this tomorrow
okay okay
or I don't know the next day wait why is
that so weird to you I mean no it just
sounds like torture because you guys are
just going to gorge and drink too much
and it's going to be miserable I have
that kind of time right now I gotta do
stuff man you know the kind of time no
I'm busy the next two weeks you know
shooting my special go to San Francisco
all right
perhaps I can go do shit tomorrow a lot
of times I can do yeah but you know you
realize you're not allowed like when you
say that you won't participate you're
not allowed to be part of the
conversation great I mean you're no
longer even allowed to call yourself the
water champion it's fine I know in my
heart Who I am
yeah sure with lamb yeah big L that's
what you are it's fine so be it so be it
I know that Bob I'm great at this I
don't need to compete it's a silly this
is childish I'm an adult your children
speaking of great fun things my to
ascend ascend I'm not sure who's in
descent but this is a major league
baseball player reading his own mother's
jokes to to a teammate of his and the
teammates reaction is almost
unbelievable it actually feels like top
dog is in the room it's a it's Monday
we're going to do mom jokes my Brett
Phillips and Wilson has a lot of corny
jokes so we're going to tell a few to
mr. Brett Phillip seriously we can't get
him to laugh so it's a his mother's joke
okay why does the stadium get hot after
the game was hot just like not the fans
left look at that guy's left
he fucking with him I don't know I think
they're both I think they're both it's
pretty funny I think this guy's is
questionable up top you know I don't
think he's a all there the guy on the
left yeah I think he's got real problems
like maybe maybe he used to play
football before he played balaam yeah
not so good how did you make an egg roll
you push it like he's really he thinks
that's really funny you think so I think
he knows that one's corny I think he
does but he's like oh my gosh it's good
it's funny why did the bicycle fall over
because they didn't have a peg it was
too tired you get that like I think he's
adding he's really like touched it a
little bit sweet guy but you know we're
tart got all the genes that play a sport
yeah yeah not a lot less time to think
about anything else
wasn't the duck side of the bartender
quack put it on my bill oh my god they
really ladder bridges like that was oh
my god they're both laughing at that
look at him look at him oh my god oh my
god what's happening oh he really thinks
it's funny good oh yes
really thinks it's funny he's like is it
may be that there's so much more
innocent than we are like they'd
probably don't sit here and talk about
you know farting and fist-fucking and
coming all day like a couple segments
you know what I'm yeah these guys don't
talk about the horrible things we do
they must be not as desensitized yeah so
what's going on uh yeah I mean this
guy's probably a really sweet guy and
yeah he's probably
has a lot to do to kindness it was hard
being nice
I remember raining these jokes off of
popsicle sticks when I was a child and I
I still was like wah wah like I never
thought they were funny it's an
intelligence factor it is you think so
of course of course it is
I don't know or you know intelligence as
in the real world experience yeah this
guy's not street savvy you know yeah he
might be I mean this is for what did the
duck say to the bartender oh my god put
it on my bill right
that's what I mean put it on my bill is
my bill okay so you're like I relax but
then really I mean come on he can't keep
it together I mean it I wish I were that
easily amused dumb broad yeah yeah yeah
I'd be too right let me so much water
that comes every time we could watch
friends I think it was the best show
ever man she would Ross it so funny hey
do that hand gesture anything and then
how do you find Will Smith in the snow
well it is that's you know George for
his Fresh Prince he doesn't get it he
doesn't get it you ain't you know huh
he's been here with the ball
yeah I'm had to him bad maybe coming
back what if his story is like this guy
in when he was 15 was beaten
relentlessly yeah that brain down yeah
somehow he was able to maintain his
ability to play baseball
oh he's in a coma
yeah yeah now we're sitting on him yes
how do you know if you're in front of a
Polish firing squad the guns are faced
if the it
I said dad dad do you not understand how
these books work you're not supposed to
actually try to answer them that's the
best day ever
that was such a good day yeah we got
them again here when I had them in Haiti
oh god I love that boy was time weirded
me that they last that hard it's weird
of me to says she left she left that
well I think your mom I mean you have to
forgive her because she's working on a
second language thing and that's really
a cultural humor yeah but I have this is
like when certain people like certain
comedians that you're like that is so
not on my radar
like why are people laughing you know I
don't get it
Jean remember the Shibuya roll call last
week yeah I was trying to forget that my
name is Cindy yeah yeah yeah I like
donut yeah yeah yeah shove my hand in my
ass
about it I was hired two years ago at a
large biotechnology seedcorn company and
we had a toned-down version of the
Shibuya cult chant we're taking the job
I spent seven months in Afghanistan
getting shot at
sometimes shooting back sleeping and
jacking off but again when I came to my
turn in the Shibuya ceremonial
ceremonial circle I was zoning out and I
froze and yelled hey my name is Andrew
clap clap and I killed a man
it's that's super quiet and they
canceled the rest of the Ori to which I
do appreciate not having to attend these
dogshit retard festivals anymore I had
to talk to HR a couple times after that
I appreciate do people my incite thanks
mommy
Andrew do you realize that that dudes
improv in that moment ended their entire
orientation it did and that's effective
and do you realize that I mean cuz
that's an unconscious thing like that
Shibuya experience was so traumatic that
it unconsciously led him to think of his
war days do you know I mean you
there's nothing worse than this oh wait
Afghanistan doll so the fact that it's
chant like you know I see you go same
beat rhythm so your brain goes into that
kind of stream of consciousness yeah and
then he was like what can I say about
myself I killed a guy yeah they're like
for maker yes when I'm Andrew are you
guys going to clap again and they're
like because you really did some someone
that could have thought also that uh
that was a confession like he killed a
civilian now like I killed my roommate
but what I got his body up Oh Andrew Oh
Lord
yeah well what's your Afghanistan better
than this possibly erect for your
service Andrew and thanks for writing
and that is an amazing story actually
this dad boner thing came in said I
actually find it to be more it's one of
these interesting you know sometimes you
like yeah that's pretty cool mmm-hmm
it's I don't know if you've seen this
yet or not but this is a dad boner wait
a minute
this again broccolis to skip a rock yeah
dude
it'll never go in and look at that
perfect skipping rock Wow
X : yeah yeah so he went to skip the
rock and I guess there's a bunch of ice
on this lake yeah
and then it the pitch turned into that
that's crazy I didn't you know as
possible neither did I it's really cool
skipping rocks on that is awesome very
elastic but I understand it Wow but I
get is again so I enter the same way
unwarranted way beautiful wherever they
are
yeah yeah yes you're doing I should but
Rock bombs away
big ones his face was frightened oh I
love this she's awesome
I'm getting way through our story out of
it I think it's really great yeah that's
fine can't make fun of that boner on
that one
no that must be a perfect thing like the
acoustics of the mountains yeah ice
pretty special it's pretty cool man yeah
I like to say ah yeah a little kid
open-faced ah oh he was so happy oh oh
oh
59 ah 50 time oh so was just exciting
things that happened all right here we
go I'm going over the new bridge
I mean that's for driving on a bridge
the trans-canada highway Oh crazy that's
one of my favorite things we've ever
discovered oh oh oh I wonder I wish I
could know the story that's one of those
things yeah I wish I could know why why
the excitement I just don't get it
mmm it is mental illness right now it
feels like it yeah gotta be craziness
yeah it feels like trying to find this
is just the pronoun song I was trying to
screw that Hey um hi how are you what's
your name what's your pronoun I feel
differently that's a difference
hey we're like hey um hi how are you
writing what's going to are you
[Music]
yes I heard you talkin shit about me at
the bar that's not the one I thought it
was you're cute hey Gert yeah
ah there's so many on Thursday put them
in the dungeon and there's less but hey
hi how are you what do you mean what you
pronounced
okay just wanna confirm what you
pronounced what you product be here here
the bender what's your credit fuck me
man okay
Chloe has my another culture is yes sir
ah yes sir
oh wow well this reminds me DJ boy
butter bun so good San Francisco in the
90s this is exactly what you saw some
wild shit you told me once that you saw
yes there guys fucking in the streets
just real crazy but fucking each other
all the time any two people fucking in
the streets it's crazy
yeah but back then I feel like SF was
way gayer and and whackier and really
more fun yeah now it's the upstairs like
us you know douche bags going the whole
foods with their kids it's a little
different not that I don't love San
Francisco guys I'm not saying that but
it's just culturally very different
since the dot Commerce came so that's uh
that's fueling us now it's not NOT the
weirdo they used to be a real beacon for
weird beards yeah it was really fucking
far-out it was really fun you like that
oh I had the bet we're the best time I
mean we just get on those Muni buses get
high will you drink beer walk around
Haight Street see fucking weird shit
used to be a guy that dressed up like
Sherlock Holmes under the freeway yeah
people was playing what's up Sherlock
well he was just yell hi Sherlock and he
what you know there was a guy in a pink
unitard on a fucking unicycle that was
on Hay Street all the time your paint
guy Sean I used to see him all the time
whoo go whoo I mean just and they're
always there just straight weird man
just all kinds of weird all kinds of
we're should now it's so know we're the
weirdos the weirdos are in Portland now
I think I think Portland is the new San
Francisco there's a lot of weirdos in
Portland yeah yeah they all kind of went
and there's a pride about it which is
interesting too is awesome yeah they're
like little fucking yeah are wearing
their ad I just pulled up this page I'm
thinking man I was 400 episodes in
normally found this I'm mom wrong yeah
that was great
that's from like a special edition
episode of cops did eh
I mean obviously they're on a regular
episode because they put it on like a
best-of type of cops tape and it was a
random YouTube find yeah a whale it's
going
shut up yeah yeah it's not there anymore
I mean we were randomly watching it and
then we were like wait what that guy
just doesn't sound like say my
or you know it's like the early days of
your mom sounds like how perfect is it
but it's like a weird things we like
playing weird segments we have you and
this guy's like I met a mom not my mom
Tom Selleck and then our first sponsor
of the show with stamps.com
and then this guy says lamb so then we
would be like this episode is brought to
you by black dot-com and then everyone
we want you to use our our website shop
through the amazon banner check out the
clip see where you can see us live go to
our website while night out from five of
them have embarked that's websites SW
does one live from five of them doesn't
have a much the best actually is not in
this is the cops with him because well
they're like how you doing today sir uh
what you doing out here
I'm mom long okay go ahead give me that
license in a registration for you lad
anyways yes you have a you have a look
anything to drink today
well you said no you have anything to
drink to that go online from five
thousand I'm on bar are going to me if I
ever turn off that car just step out for
a second like that the guy stays like so
likes treats him like he's actually
speaking in respect like a toddler yet
Jimmy if I ever go ahead and turn that
off and no step out for me and it looks
just like this guy is definitely coming
with us that's got to be the hardest
part of law enforcement is dealing with
nut bags which is the majority of law
enforcement you're just like sir sir
could you step out a guard just be
normal okay
like like the guy actually said
something sure
so babbling the other registration yeah
there's a registration on you right now
I'm sure fuckin land yeah
sled um anyways it's been you know how
crazy I tell people this at live shows I
say it all the time when they go you
know listen to podcast I love it that's
you know that's why they come out this
is the most fun thing we do night last
podcast
very far because it's really it really
is all the stupid shit
you and I have enjoyed over the years
and it's all about silly and it's great
because we come in here and we seal the
world yeah everything is sealed off and
it's just talking about stuff we really
truly care about anyway genuinely I want
to say we do appreciate everybody that
listens to the show downloads the show
and and tells us that they enjoy it
helps I happy all the time it sounds
like really goofy to say almost right
but people are like all helps me get
through my workday or it helps it's a
good distraction from whatever mundane
thing I'm doing you know I never we
never expected anybody would say that
and I think it's a it's very cool that
people enjoy it like that I think it's
so it's it overwhelms me at times when
we do the show live or I go do stand-up
and all the mommies show up yeah and
you're just like this is crazy like this
started just out of us talking about
farts and shit like that's what we
normally would talk about and to think
that it's really touched lives of so
many people yes I know that is so silly
the house at farts built yeah so anyways
we're gonna you know there's no there's
no sign of us slowing down with this
we're going to be having like I said
we've had guests lately we're bringing
some we have guests lined up coming up
some episodes we'll have them some won't
but there's you know it's one of the
most fun things we do so there's no way
we would slept slowed down or stopped
doing this 400 and hopefully 4,000 more
that's it man so it's like oh I don't
know we were wanting to do a glossary of
terms from your mind somebody start that
already I don't know but if I know the
Facebook page you guys do that could
someone start a glossary or maybe a
Wikipedia page and all the terms are
some localized place that's fans can go
you know there's got to be someone who's
in charge of all these things there you
go and I know we set it at the top but
obviously go 2000 ranch comm for tickets
to San Francisco shows and the link for
Christina Seattle special taping that's
coming up in just a couple weeks and I
announced a bunch of dates you already
know that we announced that but they're
at Tom
great I come so go there and of course
your mom's house Podcast calm that's it
for us this week
gene anything else no I think that's it
yeah
thank you good and I just I just want to
say thanks to everybody for listening
and supporting this and and I hope
everybody's jeans stay tight and high as
mine are
I wore my highest highest pair for this
episode did you see yeah look how tight
these are those are really tight a nice
job this is a doctor butt trumpet by
bananas here it is thank you guys for
making 400 so fun part hundred
[Music]
that's a good one that's that's that's a
good one that's got to have powerful
places yep
[Applause]
[Music]
I
that's a good one yes yes that's a good
one
[Music]